okay so we just finished the full day at
the office we had meetings we did a shoe
and now off to arias birthday dinner we
knew Kylie Jenner was busy but now we
know just how busy because the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star just shared
a behind-the-scenes look at a day in her
life in a vlog on YouTube have a long
day today in case you don't have 20
minutes to watch Kylie's full vid et's
here to break down 9 things we learned
about the beauty mogul starting with
this her day starts bright and early
5:50 a.m. to be exact and Kylie is just
like any other mom totally
sleep-deprived I said that I was gonna
start this vlog a lot earlier but I sell
fast or me last night she woke me up at
6 wouldn't stop crying it wasn't it
wasn't the time to grab my camera and
start filming number 7 on our countdown
Kylie's one year old baby girl stormy
already has a few words in her vocab and
it'll have you feeling feels my wake
store Mia because she's gotta go to the
farm
did you have a good seat yeah see what
your glasses
and speaking of itty-bitty stormy her
closet is stocked make you feel like you
could wear and make all these little
custom t-shirts for her yeah you heard
that right
custom t-shirts stormy also rocks the
Kardashians signature look biker shorts
and a neutral tee this time from her
uncle Scott's talentless clothing line
t-shirt do we think white paper shorts
go back to black sand she's going to the
farm but Stormy's epic wardrobe has
nothing on her famous mama's purse
closet
now I'm gonna choose a purse oh and she
even has an in-house fitting room I want
to or something pink because my whole
office is like black and paint
I love this I was in a Wang
pink jacket with the pink matching pants
I also love this pink little workers
jumpsuit she matches her outfit to her
office guys and if you were impressed
with her closet just wait until you see
her car collection I'm gonna take this
guy today number 3 on our list the 21
year old balances that boss babe
mom life like a pro
[Applause]
Kiely says stormy is a regular visitor
at the Kylie cosmetics office stormy is
in all my meetings she really is she
even has her own room it's hard to
manage
mom life and work life sometimes so
that's why I made her a bedroom here so
she could be with me and stuff fun
next up Kylie is all about comfort and
isn't afraid to rock a robe and slippers
on her commute home I'm literally gonna
wear this home cuz I'm way too
comfortable number one on our list Kylie
is one seriously generous friend I am
surprising him with a birthday dinner
not only did she throw a surprise
birthday party for her friend and makeup
artist Arielle she also gifted him some
major bling
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]